plastic crash not plastic waste
bottles used then returned by lorry
by the thousands more than half a
billion are sold each year in Norway and
almost all a recycled it's because they
have value every bottle has a deposit
the equivalent of 10 P returned to
customers when they bring back their
empties it's not much but it adds up it
can be a lot we can be frozen so kroner
every year if you have a family and also
people are collecting in streets when
they go to the ocean or to the mountains
to take it bring it back home and you
give it here
every shop that sells bottles has to
collect the empties sometimes I reverse
vending machines that give back cash
sometimes by manual bins this cinema
collects eight bags of bottles a week it
gets a small handling fee from their
central recycling scheme and a refund
for the deposits it returns to customers
it's just like culture for us we have it
like story yes maybe so works brilliance
collection trucks across Norway pick up
the empties and return them for
processing at one of three plants run by
the organization infinitum a total of
twenty-two thousand tons of bottles
passed through each year the deposit
ensures there's little contamination
from other materials a huge problem with
curbside collections 99% of these will
be recycled plastic when you make it
from oil then you use a lot of energy
if you collect the material and when you
collect it to a deposit system to a
reverse vending machine then you take
care of the material you keep it clean
actually true the value same and then
you can use it reuse it again and again
just a small deposit can make a big
difference here in Norway 96% of plastic
bottles
cycle in the UK it's less than 50% 16
million bottles every day invade
recycling many of those were going to
landfill but some will be washed out to
sea
in Scotland the government is
considering a money back scheme on
plastic just as a generation ago that
was on glass but drinks manufacturers
who support the deposit scheme in Norway
say it just won't work in the UK and the
investment has been done over a lot of
years so if you're going to do that
overnight in Scotland for instance it
will of course be very very expensive
somebody's got to do that work and
somebody's got to pay for it if it is
trash collected on a beach on the west
coast of North worldwide 8 million tons
of plastic end up in the oceans each
year it's eaten by wildlife and it's in
our food chain but in Norway the deposit
works surfers have seen the evidence
pile up most bottles come from abroad so
we have two Norwegian bottles and we
have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
non Norwegian bottles where waste has
value there's less litter people also
understand the other aspect of it you
know that you're actually only borrowing
the bottle you're buying the content but
you're borrowing the bottle and you have
to give it back because that's resources
financial incentives can clean up the
environment putting 5p on plastic bags
reduce the number of being washed up on
Britain's beaches by 40% small deposits
on bottles could have a similar effect
keeping more plastic in the recycling
loop and out of the ocean Thomas More
Sky News in Oslo